hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my face book readers Miriam
who wrote it and asking about my
favorite book so she wrote in saying
what is the most interesting and useful
book that you've ever read so thanks for
the question I get this I get asked
similar questions a lot and I've
actually created a resource on my I
think it's on the Facebook page but it's
definitely on the blog that talks about
my favorite books of all time and the
number one book that is really impact in
my life is Tim Ferriss 4-hour workweek I
think a lot of entrepreneurs have read
it it's become a somewhat of a Bible for
a lot of people who are starting the
business for me what I really liked
about it was a whole new it gets us a
couple things the first off the idea of
outsourcing so up until that point when
I first read the book everything that
I'd done and I've had staff on board but
there's been local so the idea of having
people work for you remotely was a new
concept and we've since run with it and
it had a huge impact on my business and
we people working for me now who are you
know in Holland and in Africa and in
Philippines and you know you do the
United States and all over the world
basically it's a you know virtual team
but you know they feel connecting part
of the family and so that was a really
interesting concept that really helped
me they also the idea of outsourcing
personal tasks and having a virtual
assistant who you can hire at a fraction
the rate of what you would be earning
and can save a lot of the the headaches
that you go through in your own personal
life I found that really had an impact
so on both my business and my personal
life and then what I really loved about
the book is that it teaches you to hack
into you know your business and
challenge the conventional thinking and
so since reading that book I've tried to
do some of the techniques from the book
including you know chunking your time so
you're not working you know all day long
just because most people work 9:00 to
5:00 doesn't mean you have to work 9:00
to 5:00 alright so I usually work five
hours a day four days a week now and
crunch all my work down to that
and it's worked up pretty well so thank
you Tim for I write in the great book
there's a lot of other great parts in
the book I encourage you to read it if
you haven't already read it it's he's
got two versions out already
definitely pick up the second version
it's got new cooler stories in there and
real-life examples there's other things
that might appeal to you like you know
traveling around the world and have it
do it on a budget especially but for me
I think the biggest impact was how it
can get beyond myself build a virtual
team and challenging Rachel thinking and
and believe more myself and the
abilities that I have to take my
business to the next level so I read
that book a number of years ago I've
read the you know revised version more
recently and I still try to revisit the
book once a year just again to keep
thinking you know am i doing the right
things with my business or should other
things be delegated handed off so I can
focus more of my time or what I call the
CEO time most important kind of big
picture things to be doing to grow my
business so check it out behind me right
at floral workweek and if you check out
my blog you can also see the top 10 list
of books that I recommend for
entrepreneurs to read and hope for
there's something in there that would
inspire you to continue to build and
grow your business I know they really
have an impact for me thank you for the
question if you guys liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below it
makes me want to make more of these
videos for you guys and if you have a
comment if you want to share your
favorite book is or if you want to ask
me a question feel free to leave it in
the comment section below and we'll see
you on the next episode
you